as they took the field for the first
time since in your tragedy the Buffalo
Bills wore the number three on their
uniforms a tribute to Demar Hamlin whose
terrifying Cardiac Arrest last Monday
put a stop to a game and had his
teammates fearing the worst please rise
and show yourself
[Applause]
before the game Hamlin posted online
nothing I want more than to be running
out that tunnel with my brothers God
using me in a different way today he
added a picture of himself in his
hospital bed another positive
development for a 24 year old known for
expressing love and support to others we
can't wait to see you get better and
when you're back it's going to be a huge
celebration we love you and this one's
for you today baby let's go buffalo on
the opening kickoff came a stunning
development the result an absolute
contrast to the last time they were on
the field Hamlin's doctors say he'd
likely have died if not for immediate
CPR and the use of a defibrillator on
him while on the field in hospital
Hamlin communicated at first in writing
asking doctors a question yes
yes and the answer is
Hamlin's breathing tube has since been
removed doctors say he's recovering
remarkably well and is able to speak to
his family and his care team in another
online post Hamlin said he's thankful to
everyone who's reached out and prayed
this will make me stronger on the road
to recovery Hamlin's brush with death
has some football analysts suggesting
fans should rethink their obsession with
a dangerous game
but in a country where political
partisanship has created deep divisions
Hamlin's ordeal has also brought people
together for common cause
Ross Lord Global News